Good morning, Hank. It's Friday, January 21,
2011. I want to continue our discussion about
how the truth resists simplicity by talking
about narrative complexity, but in order to
do that I need to talk about my favorite person:
ME! Okay, Hank. So the biggest award in young
adult literature is called the Printz Award,
which looks like this (award stamp on Looking
for Alaska) on a book, and looks like this
(actual Printz Award) in a basement. And the
single most important moment in my whole professional
life happened five years ago, almost to the
day, when I received the call saying that
Looking for Alaska, my first novel, had won
the Printz Award. And it was especially meaningful
to me because my first job after college was
as a temp at the magazine, Booklist. And on
my first day at Booklist, I had to retype,
that's how old I am, all these speeches that
were given at the first Printz Award reception.
And that is the good narrative, right? You
start out with this twenty-two year old professional
data entrist who writes for years and years
at night and on the weekends, and then eventually
it comes out and he wins the very award that
he used to type the speeches for. And you
can imagine this young writer working in isolation
and getting rejected over and over and over
again until a publisher takes a chance on
him. But Hank, the actual story of how this
book came to exist and have this shiny piece
of gold on it is different and more complicated
so I thought I would try to tell that story
today.
So I did write this story at night and on
the weekends for three years, but I had constant
help from my friend, Ilene Cooper, who was
one of my bosses at Booklist and who's also
an author. Ilene probably read and commented
on like a dozen drafts of Looking for Alaska--which
by the way, wasn't even called Looking for
Alaska until my friend, Keir Graff came up
with that title. Then, once Ilene was happy
and I paid Keir his two dollars for coming
up with the title, Ilene and I sent it to
Penguin and they agreed to publish it, provided
I revised extensively. Although, I had no
idea about how extensively I would have to
revise it.
So this book, for those of you who haven't
read it, is about a guy who memorizes the
last words of famous people, and falls in
love with a girl named Alaska. Only, when
Penguin agreed to buy the book, it wasn't
about a guy who memorizes the last words of
famous people. In fact, a lot of what people
like about the book, from the "Great Perhaps"
to the labyrinth, came out in those revisions
after I'd sold the book to Penguin. So Hank,
about four years after I started, I had a
reasonably finished manuscript. Although,
it would be wrong to say that I wrote that
book. The truth is that Ilene wrote parts
of it, and my editor, Julie Strauss-Gabel
wrote parts of it, and my wife wrote parts
of it. In fact, all these people wrote at
least a little bit of Looking for Alaska.
And I am grateful to each and every one of
those people, although no, they cannot have
any of my royalties.
We all like this idea that a book is created
by a single person for a single reader because
it's a narrative that makes sense, but the
truth resists that simplicity. As the great
Carl Sagan said, "If you wish to make an apple
pie from scratch, you must first invent the
universe."
So all these people worked to make a book.
It came out. Twelve people in a room decided
this award (Printz), and I was really happy.
And then a little part of me was like, so
what? What I eventually realized is that the
real business of books is not done by awards
committees, or people who turn trees into
paper, or editors, or agents, or even writers--we're
all just facilitators. The real business is
done by readers. And the Looking for Alaska
that you read is not quite like the Looking
for Alaska that anyone else reads. The hundreds
of thousands of Looking for Alaska readers'
stories are not something I can hold in my
hand or even get my head around.
But Hank, I do want to say to you and all
the Nerdfighters who've read my books, that
being able to participate in big, interesting
conversations with you through stories like
this one (Looking for Alaska) and my other
books is really the most fulfilling thing
about my life. Just kidding! It's Henry and
Sarah! But you guys are great too. Seriously,
if I didn't have such a cute kid and a great
wife, you would be at the top. Well, pizza.
It goes Sarah and Henry, pizza, the rest of
my family, Nerdfighteria, The Mountain Goats--that's
my top five. Hank! I am Freedom in Panem,
and I will see you Friday (rolls up to look
at calendar). It is Friday! I'm so bad at
that that! (while spinning around in chair
and flailing arms in agony)